[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département et tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres
[Musique]
40 c'est le nombre de sapeurs pompiers
de la caserne de saint paul qui ont été
formés aux techniques de lutte
anti-vectorielle face à l'épidémie
grandissante de dengue dans l'ouest ces
pompiers interviendront sur les foyers
identifiés des renforts supplémentaires
pour endiguer la contagion
depuis le début de l'année 588
réunionnais ont été touchés par la dame
habituellement les pompiers va on n'est
pas sollicité donc pour ce type de
mission et donc du coup on a bien voulu
prêter assistance parce qu'il ya un
manque de personnel au niveau de la rs
et c'était très important pour nous
parce que de plus en plus bas on voit
qu'il ya des cas de dengue qui se
multiplient partout dans l'île et
notamment dans l'ouest et du coup bah
pour moi c'est un acte vraiment éco
citoyens de pouvoir participer à cette
mission
aujourd'hui c'est la première édition de
la fête de l'étang saint paul pendant
deux jours le public a pu découvrir les
richesses de cette réserve naturelle
une quarantaine d'animations étaient
proposées autour de la protection de
l'environnement et la préservation de la
biodiversité pas le département
participe à ce genre de projet parce que
nous sommes nous mêmes propriétaires de
près de 40% de la surface de l'étang ici
à saint paul au titre des espaces
naturels sensibles
le débattement fait partie du conseil de
la régie de l'étang et il était
important que au même titre que la
commune de saint-paul et l'état qu'on
soit présent nous sommes présents parce
qu'il s'agit de préserver de valoriser
cet espace remarquable de l'étang saint
paul avec l'aide des plans d'eau les
plus importantes de toute la zone des
mascareignes et préserver valoriser mais
en même temps permettre aux familles de
la réunion de venir à la découverte de
ces espaces
[Musique]
une journée rien que pour vous c'est une
journée au féminin dédié aux femmes
agents de la collectivité départementale
un moment convivial qui s'est déroulée
au village corail une quinzaine
d'ateliers dédiés au bien-être étaient
proposées tout au long de la journée
voilà john de tentes pour prendre soin
de soi
essayez les ateliers maquillage
murs des palais voilà les massages way
monde et les collègues
voilà surtout serre se retrouver entre
eux à gent féminine collègues le
président du département et les élus de
saint-andré et de sainte suzanne ont
inauguré le nouveau pont enjambant la
ravine mentionne un chantier qui a coûté
1,2 million d'euros dont 480 milles ont
été financés par le département
ce nouveau pont du bras des chevrettes
permettra de maintenir la circulation
dans cette zone souvent inondée lors de
fortes pluies
de rénovation du réseau routier métiers
essentiels pour la vie quotidienne de la
population puisque ce qui est librement
et sans risque
lors des périodes cyclonique est donc
même si les montants ne soit pas énorme
mais c'est un élément structurant à
l'échelle du quartier est important pour
la vie quotidienne des habitants
il fallait protéger les piétons parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de trottoir il
fallait protéger les automobilistes
on a refait le virage on a rénové la
route
il fallait protéger les habitations
parce que nous avons un radier nous
avons mis un ouvrage qui pour qui pourra
supporter des crues centennales ce
fameux pont de la ravine maincion c'est
un ouvrage qui protège des habitations
c'est un ouvrage qui redynamise le
quartier le bonus de cette semaine c'est
un bon plan dimanche c'est pâques et
pour cette journée mascarin du jardin
botanique de la réunion propose une
chasse aux oeufs grandeur nature dans le
jardin
[Musique]